und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Unionsfraktion im Bundestag Torsten Frey
schönen guten Morgen nach
villingen-Schwenningen
schönen guten Morgen nach Berlin Herr
frei die Bundesregierung gibt gerade
keinen besonders gutes Bild ab aus
verschiedenen Gründen aber davon scheint
vor allem die AFD zu profitieren nicht
aber ihre Partei die CDU warum ist das
so
ja das ist eine Situation die uns nicht
zufriedenstellen kann ganz im Gegenteil
wir erleben eine Bundesregierung die in
vielen Bereichen passt und die ist
insbesondere nicht schafft die
Wirtschaft auch in Deutschland in
Schwung zu bringen wir erleben einen
Internationalen Währungsfonds der die
Prognosen für die Weltwirtschaft nach
oben setzt auch für andere europäische
Staaten und für Deutschland nach unten
korrigiert und in dieser Situation
glaube ich ist es ganz entscheidend das
wird den Menschen deutlich machen können
dass wir die besseren
wirtschaftspolitischen Konzepte haben
und dass wir auch die besseren Antworten
auf die Herausforderungen der Zeit haben
deswegen haben wir ganz konkret im
Bereich der hohen Energie- und
stromkostenvorschläge gemacht aber auch
darüber wie man die Wirtschaft in
Deutschland stärken kann meine Frage war
aber warum die CDU nicht von dieser
Problemlage profitiert sie dringen ja
offenbar mit ihrer Politik beim Wähler
bei der Wählerin nicht durch
ja ganz offensichtlich ist es so ich
habe davon gesprochen was aus meiner
Sicht das richtige Rezepte dieser
Situation ist aber dass wir bisher keine
durchschlagenden Erfolg haben das muss
man tatsächlich konstatieren deswegen
müssen wir glaube ich sehr viel
konzentrierter deutlich machen dass wir
gute Vorschläge haben die dafür sorgen
dass wir von den weltweit höchsten
Energie und Stromkosten runterkommen
dass das auch das richtige Rezept ist um
einen schleichenden
d-industrialisierungsprozess zu stoppen
und umgekehrt muss man eben auch
deutlich machen was die Rezepte der
anderen für unser Land bedeuten würden
das gilt zum einen für die
Koalitionspartei aber wenn sie sich am
vergangenen Wochenende den Parteitag der
AFD anschauen muss man eben auch sehr
deutlich sagen was deren Vorschläge
bedeuten würden nämlich weniger
Wohlstand für unser Land weniger
Westintegration weniger Sicherheit wir
würden zur fünften Kolonne Moskau kommen
sie haben die Wirtschaftslage
angesprochen die Union will dazu heute
eine fünf Punkte Plan vorstellen eine
Forderung darin die Stromsteuer soll
gesenkt werden gleichzeitig fordern ja
viele in Deutschland mehr Investitionen
auch um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln und
in der CDU gibt es jetzt offenbar eine
Diskussion um die Schuldenbremse berlins
Regierender Bürgermeister kein Wegner
hat vorgeschlagen die Schuldenbremse im
Bund fünf Jahre lang auszusetzen was
sagen sie
ich glaube nicht dass Deutschland ein
Einnahmeproblem hat wir haben jedes Jahr
steigende Steuereinnahmen wir werden in
Kürze die eine Billion Steuereinnahmen
pro Jahr überschreiten und deswegen gibt
es nicht ein konjunkturelles Problem in
aller erster Linie wir haben
strukturelle Probleme wir geben viel zu
viel Geld für konstruktive Ausgaben aus
viel zu wenig für investive Ausgaben
etwa in die Infrastruktur in die Bildung
in Forschung in Technologie deswegen die
eigentliche Aufgabe von Politik ist es
die richtigen Schwerpunkte zu setzen das
Geld an der richtigen Stelle für
Zukunftsinvestitionen auszugeben und das
müssen wir verstärkt machen denn die
schwarze Null ist ja kein selbstweg
sondern die schwarze Null ist ein
Ausdruck von
Generationengerechtigkeit und deswegen
lehne ich es ab dass wir Politik auf
Kosten zukünftiger Generationen macht
also nein zur Schuldenbremse von ihnen
anderes Politikfeld die Asylpolitik
vielleicht
auch ein Bereich wo sie gegen die AFD
punkten wollen sie haben sich ja frei
gegen mehr staatliche Seenotrettung im
Mittelmeer ausgesprochen das sei das
falsche Signal und ziehe mehr flüchtende
an sagen sie Experten und Experten
bezweifeln das kritiker werfen ihn
wiederum vor sie wollen da die AFD
rechts überholen
nein das ist mit Sicherheit überhaupt
nicht möglich sondern ich habe einen
konkreten Vorschlag gemacht wie man das
Asylrecht so ausgestalten könnte dass es
zum einen die hiesigen die europäischen
Gesellschaften nicht überfordert zum
anderen aber auch für diejenigen die
Schutz suchen nach Europa kommen möchten
humaner wird es kann uns ja nicht
zufriedenstellen das in den letzten zehn
Jahren etwa 30.000 Menschen im
Mittelmeer gestorben sind viele auf dem
Weg dorthin und deshalb muss man sagen
der Status Quo also so wie es ist so
kann es nicht bleiben deswegen müssen
wir uns darüber Gedanken machen wie man
das besser organisieren kann auf der
anderen Seite trifft der anstrom auch
auf ein Land das viele Probleme hat in
Deutschland fehlen 700.000 Wohnungen in
Deutschland fehlen
378.000 Kita Plätze in zwei Jahren
werden schon 25.000 Lehrerstellen nicht
besetzt sein und vieles andere mehr und
vor diesem Hintergrund Hintergrund muss
Infrastruktur auch dazu passen und
deshalb haben wir eine ganze Reihe von
Herausforderungen die die
Bundesregierung nicht angeht und nicht
bewältigt auch die Tatsache dass es
nicht gelingt dem Asylbescheid seinen
Wert zu geben Herr freilassen ist noch
kurz zum Abschluss über ihre
Machtperspektive die Machtperspektive
der Union sprechen die Linie der CDU ist
ja klar keine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
auf Bundes- und landesebenen und stehen
im nächsten Jahr gleich drei Wahlen an
in ostdeutschen Ländern Landtagswahlen
da könnte die AFD stärkste Kraft werden
wenn sie in einem Land wie Thüringen zum
Beispiel weder mit der AFD aber auch
nicht mit den Linken zusammenarbeiten
wollen heißt das für die CDU keine
Machtperspektive oder
also zunächst einmal ist es für uns
völlig unvorstellbar dass wir im
nächsten Jahr eine Situation haben wo
AFD und Linke zusammen mehr als die
Hälfte der Wähler überzeugen können und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt hart daran
arbeiten dass wir uns selbst so stark
wie irgend möglich machen dass wir für
unsere Konzepte und Ideen werden und sie
auch überzeugend darstellen können und
dann bin ich das halt auch mit dem
linken aus natürlich wissen Sie eine
Zusammenarbeit auch mit den Linken aus
in Thüringen
ja ich kann mir keine Zusammenarbeit mit
den Linken vorstellen denn Koalitionen
oder dergleichen setzen ja eine
hinreichende inhaltliche Schnittmenge
voraus und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass wir mit den Linken die eine
dezidiert sozialistische teilweise
kommunistische Politik machen dass wir
mit denen zusammenarbeiten können denn
das ist ja das Mindestmaß was sie
brauchen eine Schnittmenge auf deren
Basis dann gemeinsame Politik formuliert
werden könnte das sehe ich nicht das war
der erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der Union im Bundestag
Thorsten frei vielen Dank für das
Interview heute morgen
sehr gerne